[Music]
look in the mirror
you're doing the same thing the hedge
funds are betting against companies
we're betting on them with money and
margin we're doing the same thing the
only difference is we're winning
and you're getting your teeth kicked in
it's because they're being pulled by
strings
it's criminal behavior what happened
today plain and simple people have to go
to jail
that as you know uh was earlier in the
show dave portney who runs the sports
site bar stool
some of the smartest analysis on what
we're seeing on wall street now from a
guy with a sports site
one of the smartest pieces written on
this today came from someone who was
also not
strictly speaking a financial journalist
he covers politics and foreign policy
he's glenn greenwald he's an independent
journalist you can find his work on sub
stack we hope you support it
and we we're grateful to have mine
tonight to explain what this means you
wrote a great piece on this
today glenn there's so much to say but
how would you assess what we're seeing
with
gamestop and the hedge funds
there are a whole bunch of different
power centers in the united states many
of which we often openly discuss the
intelligence community
silicon valley the u.s government
lobbyist obviously one of the most
important and powerful if not the most
powerful
is wall street and hedge funds in
particular on wall street who are at the
top of that food chain and we almost
never talk about
how it is that they get to be
multi-billionaires without really
producing
anything of value just leaching off the
american economy taking huge amounts of
money
in exchange for nothing whatever you
think of silicon valley they get rich at
least by
producing something whatever you think
of those products these people
produce nothing they just take and they
just take and they take
and so for the first time not only are
we seeing them
have pain inflicted on them not by
people who are stealing from them or who
are committing crimes or people who have
figured out their game
and learned how to exploit it by doing
what they should do which is be
studying it but they're also getting
dragged out into the sunlight so for the
first time we're talking about people
like
melvin capital and citadel and hedge
fund short sellers and understanding
what it is that they're doing to this
country and it only happened tucker
because the internet a free internet
when it's free
enables citizens to band together in
large enough numbers to challenge
these ruling class elites and that's why
we talk so much about
the imperative nature of defending the
internet from surveillance defending it
from censorship
it is a very powerful weapon in the
hands of citizens
against ruling class elites and that's
why they're so bent upon
seizing it back controlling it
regulating it and censoring it
i think you make such a wise point if i
made a billion dollars
people would say where did you make a
billion dollars and for what and i would
feel
incumbent upon me the responsibility to
explain what i did
i never hear anybody discuss what the
upper echelons of finance
have really done or as you point out
contributed to become billionaires like
why is that not a
conversation we're having all the time
right and the other thing that i think
is so interesting in this particular
case is you see
people on the left and people on the
right reacting in very similar ways
namely in favor of
what these redditors did to these hedge
funds why because
if you're on the right what you believe
in generally traditionally
is free market economics right if you're
on the left what you believe in is
government intervention in the economy
to help the neediest
we have neither of those what we have is
a totally rigged system where the
government
constantly intervenes in the economy but
not to help people who are in need but
to help
the richest and most powerful who are
funded and owned and controlled by those
very rich people who fund their
campaigns who pay their lobbyists who
give them enormous speaking fees when
they're out of power
and it's a system that no one either on
the left or the right supports the only
people who are supported
are these establishments centrist in
both wings of the parties
and they see these people uniting
against them and that's why they're
desperate to reimpose a wedge between us
so that we can't unite anymore
but there's a realignment coming which
is the good news
the great glenn greenwald thank you